était une
un étang
l état tellement puissant tellement fort
etc
il n'a pas vu sa propre des cas
l etat
y régnait de façon quasi monopolistique
sur le monde entier concentré les plus
grandes richesses les plus grandes
villes la meilleure technologie la
meilleure arme et rien ne semble lui
résister une intégration parfaitement
réussi la première fois dans l'histoire
que la classe moyenne et eni et puis
pourtant la ligue ophrenie de ses élites
à pousser à une déchéance totale des
séances d'abord par des vagues de
migrants qui ont tenté leur chance dans
un état qui n'était déjà plus un
puisqu'il avait lui-même détruit sa
classe moyenne à force de la surtaxe et
avait dégoûté absolument tout le monde
de faire du commerce et avait
sous-traité la moitié de ces
technologies bien au-delà de ses
frontières
c'était à la à vue ces élites évidemment
partir tuer ses élites par jalousie de
ses élites politiques et a fini par
succomber
toute allusion évidemment avec l'europe
d'aujourd'hui ne serait que purement
fortuite puisque je vous parle de
l'empiré romain d'occident
alors l'europe d'aujourd'hui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes un problème
technologique
j'aurais beaucoup aimé d'ailleurs comme
vous le voyez sur la première
diapositives non je vais vous le montrer
sur non pas sur l'écran
peut-être vous dit bonjour parce que
même quand ces temps on nous écoute a
donc ça c'est l'europe d'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que si j'avais voulu vous
faire un beau diaporama j'aurais dû
utiliser un software qui n'est pas de
chez nous un ordinateur qui n'est pas de
chez nous des programmes qui ne sont pas
de chez nous et être gentiment espionnés
par des gens auxquels on dit bonjour
et pourtant c'est le fruit de la pensée
occidentale depuis la renaissance le
siècle des lumières la photographie le
cryptage tout ça le multimédia le
minitel pas les inventions doutre
pacifique ou d'outre-atlantique
le gros problème c'est que nos propres
élites n'ont pas vu ça
et qu'aujourd'hui on est aux mains des
vandales non madame non monsieur sait
pas ce qu'ils cassent votre porte
d'entrée c'est pas ceux qui feront votre
voiture c'est pas ceux qui taxent votre
immeuble
le vandale aux petites revanches
mesquine que l'europe a pris sur eux en
leur donnant cette attribution conclure
connaît aujourd'hui était un peuple
extrêmement érudit mercenaires de rome
y'en a simplement être eu marre d'être
sous traitants puisque il assuré les
frontières de roms
il était parfaitement organisé
parfaitement christianisée et qu'au vu
de la façon dont l'empereur avec les
pays a décidé simplement de migrer ce
fut une promenade de plaisir pour eux
que de défaire légion après légion
toutes les troupes romaines qui était
stationnée en gaule en ibérie et de
prendre possession de l'afrique alors
les vandales d'hyères qu'ont-ils fait
quand il était en afrique
ils ont simplement remis en état l'ordre
et la technologie romaine donc on sait
que à la même époque
besançon venait de perdre 90 % de sa
population
on y mourrait à 20 ans à l'époque où
normalement on devait mourir à 50 ans
anna en afrique du nord s'était de
nouveau le cas on mourait à 50 ans on
avait accédé à des latrines de l'eau
publique des termes et à la naissance
d'un énorme courants philosophiques et
celui de saint-augustin donc un de nos
propres repères il n'est pas né en
europe
il était d'ailleurs à l'encontre des
grandes théories philosophiques christ
chrétienne de l'époque et c'est ce noyau
la intellectuelle qui va rayonner sur
l'ensemble amélie talent c'est
rayonnement intellectuel va être doublée
d'une technologie qui était celle de la
céramique de luxe qui est une invention
italienne que l'italie ne savait plus
produire depuis 200 ans et donc les
ateliers africains vont inonder le
marché méditerranéen de cette même
céramique qui avait été inventé et là
c'est la cour impériale qui va en
profiter la première puisque les plus
belles céramiques de la cour impériale
sur les servic produite dans l'afrique
vandal
et puis bon il ya eu les uns alors les
uns c'est assez intéressant puisque
combien d'officiers combien de généraux
à ton formés dans nos écoles attila
attila ce n'était pas du tout un sauvage
c'était le fils d'un très noble 1 et
selon la coutume il a été pris dans sa
famille comme otages à 6 ont simplement
qu'un otage à l'époque de sang bleu
assez toute sa jeunesse à être éduqué
par les meilleurs rhéteur à être formés
par les meilleurs grammairien les
meilleurs mathématiciens et surtout à
comprendre parfaitement l'art militaire
puisqu'il faisait partie de la cour
impériale en l'occurrence celle de
byzance et donc il a appris parfaitement
quels étaient les stratégies et les
manoeuvres et les forces à disposition
des deux empires occidentaux et
orientaux et donc ce ne fut qu'un jeu
finalement pour lui que d'envahir toute
l'europe et de l'appuyer pas par plaisir
mais le disons c'est tel mode de sa
propre tribu qui a eu beaucoup de peine
à fédérer autour de lui et qui lui
coûtera la vie toujours vécu dans la m
hantise d'être empoisonné par des
princes rivaux mais c'est une créature
de l' empire romain c'est quelqu'un qui
parlait parfaitement grec et le latin et
qui savait par coeur toutes les grandes
théories philosophiques de l'époque pour
se défendre contre les 1
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a fait appel
au bout alors là aussi une tribu venu de
l'extrême orient qui s'est très
rapidement christianisée ce qui est une
première expulsion puisqu'elle faisait
partie de l'élite impériale puisque elle
refusait par l'arianisme refuse l
égalité dans la sainte trinité
donc on a expulsé légaux et on les a
pris uniquement comme mercenaires on
s'est retrouvé tout d'un coup avec le
dernier empereur de rome dont le
meilleur général et est illico un très
riche go devenu citoyen romain marié à
sérénac était une noble de l'élite de
rome et qui défend des
les frontières de l'empiré avec alaric
qui lui est un droit des goûts
simplement que l'empereur tellement
jaloux des succès le syli qu'on a
commencé à ne pas payer a light donc
qu'il y qu'on n'avait plus les
mercenaires à sa disposition
et ensuite il l'a gentiment fait
décapiter parce qu'il était plus
populaire que lui donc comme exemple de
suicide organisé d'une année tard entier
ce n'était pas difficile simplement que
les goûts étaient des frères d'armes
avant tout donc la première vengeance
d'alaric va être de détruire ravel la
cour impériale et de prendre rome et
surtout de rapatrier le cadavre de
serena pour l'enterrer avec celui de
style y conte à milan la technologie
d'aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est quelque
chose que nous avons pensé que nous
avons créée qui nous échappe totalement
donc il faut simplement raison garder
l'europe est le continent le plus haut
taux flageller à tard possible
on a toujours su créé les armes pour ne
se faire battre tout seul tout le monde
notre histoire depuis l' empire romain à
travers le moyen-âge quand on n'était
pas en train de se taper dessus
on essayait de faire de la renaissance
man donc le côté positif pour
l'archéologue que je suis ses devoirs en
épisodes accéléré 11 vraiment à vitesse
10 fois voire 100 fois la décadence
complète de l' empire romain qui se
passe sous nos yeux
donc l'europe paradoxalement et c'est là
la bonne nouvelle a toujours su renaître
plus forte de ses cendres pour autant
qu'elle réalise qu'elle est aujourd'hui
temps guerre qu'elle est en train de la
perdre qu'elle va la perdre et qu'on va
pouvoir faire renaître la dessus un
nouveau concept une nouvelle idée des
nouvelles élites et les nouvelles
technologies
maintenant comme vous le voyez on en est
à la période de l'écran noir tout ce que
vous mettez là dessus à moins d'être un
spécialiste est gentil mon fils très
écoutée entassés par tous que les
nouveaux grec d'aujourd'hui vos vendeurs
avoue troyan puisque tout est gratuit
miraculeuse it et du cadeau des grecs
gratuite
pas pour rien qu'on appelle un troyen un
virus un troyen
tout est gratuit évidemment vous le
nourrissez à force de donner la donne et
vaut plus que le bitcoin qui vaut 1802
là pas de problème c'est gratuit on vous
l'offre
c'est magnifique parce que comme la
distribution des spectacles dans
l'antiquité ça maintient l'homme dans sa
végétation
ça vous livre les régénérer les
résultats que vous voulez avoir ça vous
fait correspondre
tout ce que vous voulez chercher puisque
de toute façon aucun moteur de recherche
ne dépasse les 10% ce qui se trouve
vraiment sur le net non encore une fois
des technologies qu'ils nous
appartiennent pas et qui me dicte notre
façon de penser
c'est un peu le nouvel opium des peuples
si on veut mais 5e qui rend très sage
donc on a gentiment coloniser
économiquement politiquement et tout le
reste
y at il des leçons là-dessus au niveau
individuel
oui il y en a certainement beaucoup la
première attiré 700 adapté de faire avec
on peut pas faire contre peut plus faire
contre selon nos modèles qui sont
complètement dépassés archaïque et j'y
sens on peut immigrés
c'est une bonne idée le nouvel empire
romain c'est à dire qu'à l'epoque
byzance
maintenant il est de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique on paye en fonction du
mérite et pas en fonction du poste et
certains souffre de pertes ou trop
longtemps politiquement parlant
et on peut faire fortune avec de bonnes
idées pour ensuite revenir chez nous ce
que les européens d'ailleurs fait après
la deuxième guerre mondiale un beaucoup
de pays d'europe sont venus dans des
pays plus riches maintenant un à un les
pays d'europe centrale dont les plus
pauvres charge leur fortune dans les
pays d'europe occidentale
mais la vache à lait les terminer cent
ans on va bientôt arriver à réduire
notre espérance de vie sauf pour les
plus riches qui pour mêler fils y ait
des services dont bénéficiait à l'époque
l'empereur de l'empiré romain d'occident
donc
c'est par une note de joyeuses optimiste
puisque l'europe n'a jamais su briller
autant qu'après cette auto détruite que
je terminerai cette très courte
présentation
les oeufs sont déjà là puisqu'on a déjà
vu les attaques créent ce qu'elles ont
coûté aux entreprises françaises
essaient les attaques lancées n'ont pas
ciblé les attaques dans l'air donc il
fallait bien être vulnérable et bien
n'avoir rien compris
pour ces êtres pris en plein la figure
donc ça ça existe ça il faudra lutter
contre par contre les vandales et les
goûts faut pas en avoir peur il faut
simplement essayer pas trop les
provoquer et l'utiliser l'intelligence
européenne parce qu'on en a encore on a
beaucoup de talent pour essayer d'être
en compétition intelligente avec eux et
pour cela il faut se défendre
numériquement comme eux le savent le
faire merci beaucoup